en ce moment,
je suis préoccupé par les droits de l'homme
et les violations des droits de l'homme au vietnam
et ma demande au
public commence aux états-unis que les
citoyens américains
fassent savoir qu'ils sont prêts à
parrainer des familles vietnamiennes
et à aider à les payer et à les accueillir
et c'est ce que j'ai
suggéré au public ce soir
non je n'ai jamais défendu le gouvernement
du vietnam j'ai parlé pour les gens à l'intérieur du vietnam
j'étais contre la violence que ce
pays a perpétrée à l'intérieur du
vietnam mais j'étais également
contre qu'un garçon américain soit abattu
d'un  avion comme j'étais
les femmes et les enfants du vietnam
bombardés donc
il n'a jamais été possible que ma position
soit claire, en
particulier quelque part comme la france où
mouvement pour la paix
signifie gauche je ne suis pas laissé
euh je pense que nous sommes tous politiques et
tout ce que nous faisons  est politique,
nous savons que
nous ne nous reverrons peut-être jamais
avant de
laisser revivre ce moment,
nous ne dirons pas au revoir
jusqu'à la dernière minute,
je tends la main
et mon cœur sera  dedans
pour tout ce que nous savons, tout
cela peut
être un rêve
nous allons et venons
comme les ondulations comme les ondulations
d'un ruisseau
alors bébé aime-moi
aime-moi ce soir
et demain a été fait pour certains
ah mais demain
mais demain ne viendra peut-être jamais
pour tous  nous savons que
oui demain ne viendra peut-être jamais
pour tout
ce
que nous savons